Musiker Bleistift habe der Person und
ich begegnete Ehre und bis stinkt
Bründler denn fühle mich auch richtig
mies ja und das Gefühl das finde ich so
Haslacher form for extreme Unehrlichkeit
dass Du schlechter wirklich davor
schützt wirklich bösartig wenn du der
Person
[Musik]
und Informationen historische
Schutzfunktion also wenn ich jetzt sage
ja
ich will
Wassertonne
extrem problematisch ist dass man
eigenes NOZ Rust sieht die andere
vertrauen und umso schöner Schiene das
machen wir das wirklich leid
wie viel Grad der Burton Russell the
philosopher diese Woche wäre ich sogar
Zeit also
das möchte ich nur interessant findet
wenn es um Gott und
die Neugier der Weisheit am geschuldet
sondern Neugier vom Laster und das zeigt
irgendwie so dass er
aufgrund dieses
Ventil
Situation in anderem Land und du bist in
der Gruppe und du hörst das nicht
versagt Günter zu deiner Person sage
oder ich sehe das anders
du dies mir doch Ali besitze ich nicht
so ganz hin ohne großen machen und ich
habe mich unbedingt ganz viel probiert
aufgefallen ist dass das dann sagen wir
denn
[Gelächter]
Noten um darf aber Luke movie saublöd
die Anbieter und und das sind die
wirklichen übelstein
Duft und zweite nicht Klatsch und
Tratsch
Hietzing abgelöst wurde Gürtel Fake News
also das und die Polarisierung
Facebook funktioniert
ich habe den stöckweg mit aber das kühl
wo wir irgendwie wüsste die andere
machen oder Blaise Pascal et ist in der
Pause sie mich in großer wer schrieb
wenn blüht wüsstet was von Anzeige dann
gab es nicht vier Freunde auf der Reise
und das ist doch Hintergrund bestimmt
irgendwo durch mit dem Rachen
Lied und die Rache durch die das dann
brauche ich nicht haben sind doch so
zivilisiert und die sind gleich da und
daher bezahlt immer noch oder immer
blöder Spruch
und ich glaube das ist die Ventil
Funktion das ist
einfach perfekt
der kann auch wunderbar zum Thema
Klatsch und Tratsch und zum leichter und
fake-news und so weiter denn hin und
zurück 12. einseitig mit dem Vincent
Hendricks zu filterlos und Fake News und
Sandra mit der Kübra gümüsay und m
Bernhard Pörksen zur Frage wie man
eigentlich ein guter Dialog ist kurz
sprechen dann anziehen